- All right y'all, before we go
I have one last story
that might make you smile,
this is "What I'm Liking."
(upbeat music)
Earlier, we talked about
our love for books,
something many of us share,
that also includes a
Utah woman who went viral
for creating mini books, check this out.
- Was it absolutely necessary
to make tiny replicas of the books
that I've read over the last year
just so that I could put them in a jar
and have a visual representation
of my own accomplishments
for my own validation?
No, no, it was not necessary.
Do I regret spending two and a half hours
of my night last night making them?
Also no, they're my favorite thing
and I regret nothing.
- Oh my God
(audience clapping)
She needs a show, she's so funny.
They look adorable and
after the video went viral
her inbox was flooded with messages
asking how she made them
and probably just as many
saying how funny she is.
We have Stevie on the line right now
who watches on KSL-TV in Salt Lake City.
(audience cheering)
What's up Stevie?
- Hi.
- You, I have to lead with, yes
this is such a cool idea,
but you are so funny.
Your comedic timing is on point ma'am.
- Thank you.
- So, where did you get the idea from?
- Well, you know, I'd seen a similar trend
with Christmas ornaments
and people were tracking
the books that they had read
like in a Christmas ornament.
And it was, it inspired me
'cause I have this kind of silly problem
where, like only half
of the books that I read
are like the physical book
and the rest are digital or audible
and I know that that's a hot take
and that some people are gonna say
that doesn't count as reading,
but it is my jar and it counts 'cause
I'm the one reading them.
(host laughing)
But this was like,
this was the perfect
solution for that, right?
Like I could have of my audio books,
my digital books, and
nobody knows the difference.
So that's where I kind of got the idea.
But I played around with the design.
I figured out how I wanted to make them.
And then I spent a night and
a bottle of wine making them.
I made a little over 20 of them,
I think.
- [Host] Yeah.
- And I've added to it since then.
In fact we have a new addition to the jar.
- [Host] Yes, "Pieces Of Her."
- It's Karen Slaughter's
"Pieces Of Her."
(audience clapping)
It's a Netflix series now.
Highly recommend, fantastic book.
- I love that.
I actually love you read the "Dutch House"
and "The Midnight Library."
I love those two, I read those as well.
I was trying to, I was
peeking at all your books
while I was looking.
Thank you so much, Stevie.
I'm liking your post right
now, but I'm loving you.
(audience clapping)
That's not all, our season-long partner,
Pilot Pen Makers Of G2,
The Go To Pen Of The Kelly Clarkson Show
wanna honor ultimate
overachievers, just like you ma'am,
so they're gonna be writing you a check
for a thousand dollars just
'cause we think you're cool.
(host chuckles)
- Oh my God.
(audience cheering)
- All right, thank you so much Stevie,
have a good day.